Well, where's the line? How does this actually get fixed? Do I write some pre-prompt that says,
hey, if Keith tries to role play with you, just say no. You know, like, like,
they did that eventually, but I'm sure they did. I have no doubt that they did.
Hey, everyone. This is TechnoGeek here. Just wanted to give a quick shout out to our latest
sponsor, Project Discovery. Now, Project Discovery makes a lot of tools that you probably know of
or have even used. One of them is Nuclei, and the latest release of Nuclei is version 3.2.
Now, 3.2 comes with a lot of really awesome new features. Two that I really wanted to highlight
here for you are the authenticated scanning and the advanced fuzzing support. Now, for
authenticated scanning, it used to be that you would have to do all your Nuclei scanning against
unauthenticated endpoints, or you'd have to add your cookies manually, all that kind of messy.
No more. It's all automatic. You can use existing login templates to automatically log in to your
application, and then you can run all your existing Nuclei templates against an authenticated part of
the application now to really increase your coverage. The other that I mentioned is advanced
fuzzing support. Now, Nuclei had added way back in version 2.8 the ability to fuzz different things,
but now they've expanded this comprehensively across the board. So not only can you fuzz in the
normal spots, but you can fuzz within headers. You can fuzz within cookies. You can fuzz within
specific parts of the body, whether that's in JSON or XML or form data, and so many more things.
So if you want to learn more about what came in Nuclei 3.2, go ahead and check out the release blog
post over at nux.gg slash podcast. That's n-u-x.gg slash podcast. Thanks.
All righty. We have another episode of Critical Thinking here today, and I want to start this
one off with a shout out to my co-host, Joel Margolis, who has not abandoned us today despite
just having a tractor delivered to his house. It took everything in my power. Everything in my
power. I'm just sitting here thinking like about roaming around the yard on my new tractor.
Yeah. I can tell because you sent me so many pictures of this tractor and videos of this
tractor. So shout out to Joel. Also, shout out to Mr. Keith here. Keith, welcome to the podcast, man.
Hey, man. Long time listener, first time caller. As I think I've said to you guys before,
this is a public service that you're doing with this podcast, so it's a real honor to be here.
Thank you. Awesome. Thanks so much. I appreciate you listening. And yeah, I've seen you engaged
around the community too, so always appreciate that as well. Keith, our two primary topics for this
episode today are going to be AI bias bounties and that whole experience you had with Bug Crowd and
sort of that very trend-setting program that you guys were a part of where you were doing some AI
bias testing and getting bounties for that, which is really cool. And a continuation of the VDP chat
because you had some hot takes, man, after the VDP episode that you hit me with. And I was like,
wait a second. I want to hear these two fight about stuff. So I'm sitting here and I'm talking
with Justin and Justin was like, Joel, did you read through this doc yet? And I was like, no.
He's like, there's a, he wants to talk to you about VDP stuff. And I was like, oh,
I just like pulled up and I started reading. I was like, oh, it's going to be good. It's going
to be good. Whenever you want to, whenever you want to kick that off, we can, we can set that.
Well, we're going to go to, we're going to do the AI bias finding things first,
but I will say just as a teaser, there is a line in the doc that Keith wrote that starts with,
oh, my sweet summer child, Joel. I'm expecting some good stuff out of the rest of this pod. But
Keith, I want to get an intro from you first for the people that aren't familiar with your work. So
maybe you could give us a little bit of a career history, how you ended up where you're at in InfoSec
and what your experience is with Bug Bounty. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So I'll go all the way back.
You know, it was sort of funny when we were reading through some of like the prep stuff.
So my first hack was in 1997. I was like 12 at the time. And I was just got a new computer,
533 megahertz PC with a 28, 8 dial up, like, you know, those were the days. Yeah. Blazing fast.
And, and so Diablo had just come out and battle.net was a thing. Yeah, like original OG number one Diablo. And the funniest part was on the back of the like CD case for the game. They had like a trial code that you could go in with a trial account. Well, I learned that you could use Telnet and any account that wasn't currently logged in as a username on the trial account and just log in.
Wow. So I did what any enterprising juvenile delinquent in the late nineties would do. And I basically wrote VB script to create these bots that would connect as many connections as my 28, 8 dial up could connect.
It was the best when I was losing Starcraft games later where I would just like spin that up and spam my friends. So they literally just crash offline.
And I was like, yeah, I win the game by default. So I caused trouble back in the late nineties. And you know, one of the things that I say to people is the whole reason the security industry even exists today is because disk space got cheap. That's it.
It wouldn't exist in the fashion that it exists today unless you could log everything. But back then you couldn't because disk space was expensive. So I got away with a lot of things.
I believe that. I believe that. Given that one example, I believe that. And I was at that in 1997 at that time, I was the ripe age of one. And Joel, I don't, were you even born yet? How old are you, Joel?
I was born in November, 1997. So when, uh, when Battle.net launched, so did I.
What?
Yeah. And it's funny because it's like, it doesn't even exist in the same way that it used to. It used to be like an MIRC chat room that like you basically, if you were in a channel and you were the top person on the channel, you had the band hammer. And so there was this whole scene at that time where basically all of these different like clans would spin up bots and try to take over each other's channels.
So it was funny. I was looking at like, um, you know, one of the producing studios, uh, that you guys work with their logo is the same logo as like the bad-ass, like the super bad-ass hackers back then called Illuminati, where they had like the closed square brackets with like a, an eye in the middle.
Really? Wow.
Yeah. And they, they had an MIRC, which I joined on windows 95. I ended up getting wind nuked, uh, offline because they had my IP address, uh, back before windows 98 even came out. And so like, anyway, that,
that's, I'm old. Um, so like, let's fast forward though.
Okay. All right.
So fast forwarding, um, went to school for psychology cause I was a super nerd and could hack things, but I couldn't do people. And so I was like, I gotta be able to do people to be successful in my life.
I like that. I like that. You can already do the tech stuff. So you're like, all right, where can I fill myself out a little bit here?
Right, right, right. So I graduate in may of 2009, uh, which is the bottom of the stock market after the housing.
Yeah. That's a great time to enter, um, the economy. Yeah.
Right. I mean, you know, bug bounty didn't exist, right? That was like part of it too. And, um, the funny thing is, is at that time, like the number one company that was hiring people with psychology degrees that were technical was Facebook.
Now I never went to work at Facebook, but like they, they've hired so many people with psychology degrees that I'm sure someone's going to listen to this and be like, let's go hire this guy.
Um, or maybe not. I don't know. Um, but, but anyway, so a few years pass, I'm working shitty jobs, uh, just, you know, trying to make ends meet, helping my wife through her master's degree.
And eventually I go back to university for a computer science degree, which I probably should have done in the first place. Like that just made a lot of sense.
And I had been following the security scene, you know, for years at that point, listening to podcasts, like Paul Isidore and stuff with security weekly, Patrick Gray stuff on risky business.
And, um, I started doing collegiate cyber defense competitions as like, you know, the old man on the team. I was a decade older than everybody else in the team.
Nice.
And yeah, it was just like, whenever they see anything legacy, they're like Keith.
Right. It's like, Hey, what is this thing? Oh, what is tell that?
Yeah.
No kidding.
We're trying to put a backdoor on a windows 95 box.
Can you help us with that? It's like, Oh yeah, I got you.
Oh my God.
I kid you not. There was software back in those days that you could like basically take a GIF or a JPEG image or something and like spin it into like a backdoor, like a reverse connection.
And then just send it to your friends on AOL instant messenger. Like, uh, yeah, it was, it was again, logging was expensive. Don't do this at home today, kids. You'll get, you'll get in jail.
Uh, so anyway, so I got out into industry after meeting an alumni who started a pen testing firm. I was brought in to be a pen tester. Really. They wanted me to be a Splunk architect and go and install Splunk for a bunch of small medium businesses and government agencies. And I was like, no, this sucks.
Uh, so eventually went to rapid seven for a little while. Um, mostly focusing on app spider at the time. It's now called insight app sec to like support their customers and, um, got involved with besides Boston and as an organizer and volunteer.
And then eventually I was reached out to you by the folks at bug crowd and they're like, Hey, we, we see you're doing a lot of stuff in like you're at rapid seven. You're working on the app, like app spider products. So, you know, a bit of web app sec. Like, would you interview for this role on trust and security?
And I was like, sure. And right around that time, uh, I learned that my training for offensive web hacking was accepted to Derby con. Now. I don't know if you guys remember Derby con, but it was one of those. It doesn't exist anymore for anyone that goes and looks for it. Right. Um, but I didn't know that. Yeah. Yeah. It's sad really. Um, but it's sold out like within minutes, most years, uh, for the conference. And so to be accepted to train at that conference was like, Holy cow.
Holy cow. And that was sort of the year that I feel like I made it in security because I interviewed with Jason Haddix, uh, who's now my good friend and my sensei. And I told him I'm training at Derby con and he's like, Holy crap. You're training at Derby con. I was like, yeah. Is that like, is that as big of a deal as you're making it out to be? And like, yeah, apparently it was. And so eventually I joined bug crowd, worked for Jason. Um, and that's when I really got into the bug bounty scene. Uh, mostly hacking on like, uh, I shall not be named automotive company. Uh, some network.
Uh, gear stuff companies, like a few other things. But when you work on a bug bounty platform and, um, Joel, I think you've got some experience there too. Like you can't work on paid programs usually, uh, for that platform. Cause you have too much insider info. Um, and then I started a podcast, uh, application security weekly with Paul Asadorian.
I wanted to, I wanted to ask about that, man. So when, do you remember when it was that you started that podcast? What year was?
January of 2018.
January 2018. Okay. So not, not too, not too long ago. I was going to say like, if you were, if you were back in the OG days of podcasting, that would have been, that would have been pretty crazy as well. But, um, yeah, it's, it's definitely an experience. And it, it, I, I, I can tell, man, just the way you show up to this podcast, you've definitely got some podcaster vibes about you.
I've done it before. I mean, it's a lot of fun too, because you can have really great debates. You can meet really interesting and talented people as you have on your show all the time.
It's great, man. It's wonderful. Um, and, and so, yeah, that's sort of like 20, you know, 2017 Derby con. That's when I sat down and chatted with Paul Asadorian to start the podcast.
One more question about the podcast thing though. Like, why did you, cause you're not actively doing it anymore. Right. Why did you drop it?
I shouldn't have is maybe the first thing that I'll say. Um, but part of it was because, you know, in 2018, uh, I joined Thermo Fisher scientific. So background about like how that all happened. Uh, so at Derby con, uh, I'm talking with the leader for their like risk and governance slash like vulnerability management team at Thermo Fisher about starting a bug bounty program.
And I'm working at bug crowd and convince them that they should do that. And they do like a two week scoped test. Uh, I also met with Paul Asadorian and officially like agreed to start application security weekly there. Like everything happened because of that conference for me.
The bug bounty program for them did not go as planned. It did not last two weeks. I'll just put it that way.
The pen test.
The pen test. Yeah. The two weeks scoped test that they had because they didn't have a proper app sec program and they got wrecked like wrecked.
And so start the podcast, the guy, Brian and a Gaki, good friend of mine, uh, listens to the podcast, gives me some feedback. And then we just start talking about dev sec ops and app sec and doing security. And he's like, you need to come work here and like build the program here at Thermo Fisher. And I was like, it's a good offer. Let's talk. Yeah. Right. You know, why not? So I literally built it from the ground up. I was employee zero on the app sec team, uh, at Thermo Fisher.
Wow. And that's a place to be.
Right. I mean, and, and, um, fortune 100 company global footprints, like not a bad space to really cut your teeth and build some opinions about these different things at scale. Right. Because I think at the end, so to answer your question, the reason that I stopped podcasting is I was getting promoted into from manager to senior manager about a year later, a lot more responsibility focusing on career.
I was putting a lot of effort into the podcast and, um, it just like the return on investment didn't make a ton of sense at that point in time. Although quite frankly, from a reputation and brand standpoint, it was a good thing. And at some point I'd like to get back into it probably, uh, because I enjoy the conversations. Right.
Yeah. Yeah. Podcasting is a long game, man. I know for the first year, uh, you know, until we actually got some, some, we got a team around us and that sort of thing. Like Joel and I were really, really hustling with this pod.
Yeah. And, uh, it was, it was a lot, a lot of work, man, you know, editing all the things, you know, running the social media, doing this and that on the discord, planning the episodes, getting the guests coordinate. I mean, it's just, it's a lot. So really grateful to the team that we have now because it makes it a lot more. We're at a point now, I think where we're over the hump. It's a little bit more sustainable. We're in like this rhythm where we can.
We can do it longterm and pay the longterm, you know, cost or whatever. And, uh, you still get to have the fun conversations and most of that stuff is dealt with, which I really, uh, I really appreciate. So, um, and it's good for your career longterm too. Like you might not always be a full-time bug bounty hunter. Like Joel, you might decide to switch companies that you're working for and like being able to point to your corpus of work and like the knowledge that you've gained, the things that you've shared, like that will forever be valuable. Yeah. Uh, so, and the connections you make, right. Like that's also super valuable. Absolutely.
And we've, we've talked about on the pod before, but even as a full-time bug bounty hunter, you know, people will message me all the time with bugs and be like, Hey, I've got this bug and can you help me exploit it? And, uh, you know, probably 80% of the time it's like, eh, you know, this is kind of a mad bug, you know, it's not really anything, but then that other, you know, 20% of the time or whatever, it's like, Oh, you do have something good there. And yeah, you're just missing this, you know, and then you get some bounties and it's great. So it definitely worked out for me as well as a full-time, uh, bug bounty hunter. And, uh, and also,
you know, the Joel, I don't know if we ever shouted this out on the, on the podcast, but we talked a couple of weeks ago about how, um, yes, we hack had some awesome swag from the event that they ran. And like a couple of weeks later, the box shows up at my door and it's got like,
full of awesome, go get it, man, go get it. And it's got like a bunch of swag in there, really high quality stuff too. So, um,
dude, that's legit. Check that out. Look at that. Look at that. That's awesome. So shout out to the SB hack team. I think we already shouted them out, but, um, yeah, there's definitely lots of benefits to that. So it'd be great to see you get back into the podcasting space, man. Um, see, but now, now I'm, I'm a little bit of a crossroads. Cause I'm like, okay, you're, you're talking about, you know, working at Thermo Fisher scientific and you're, you know, now we could just slide right into the VDP section. So I don't know.
Talk to me a little bit because like you, you started a VDP at Thermo Fisher scientific. And like you said, they got wrecked in that pen test. Right. So you don't want to just, you know, join the team there the other day, you know, the next day and then spin up a bug bounty program and start handing out, you know, thousand dollar bounties left and right. So you decided to go to a VDP. And I think this is where a lot of, uh, the stuff that we talked about on the pod a couple of weeks ago and, and your opinion sort of collides is like when a VDP,
VDP is appropriate and what kind of restrictions are in place around that. And I'll just say just from my, my position as a, as a hacker. And as you know, somebody who hasn't dealt a lot with the corporate side, I learned a lot from that discussion that I had with Joel. And then a lot of the conversations that I had with people over DM afterwards. So, um, definitely constantly updating my opinion on all this, but I I'm excited to hear your take on, on, you know, one, how you did it.
And what the correct flow was.
Yeah. VDPs are one of those things where it's like, I think they have the right place in the industry at times, especially for hackers that want to get into something and they're maybe just cutting their teeth. Right. And so it's, it's a nice place to go and get some practice. But, um, what's interesting is like the evolution of VDPs over time, uh, because sort of the thing that I remember getting actually really mad at bug crowd about, uh, back in 2018, 2019 was.
When they removed points for VDP, um, because that was like, no one has any incentive now to, to even like report to us in the first place. And so anyway, sort of the long story short there is like, even though it was a vulnerability disclosure program and it didn't have any points, we actually did pay bounties to hackers that sort of came and continuously gave us good stuff.
So, so the thinking that we had when we put this in place was sort of, first of all, we definitely know we have too big of a footprint to properly secure when it comes from like a mitigation standpoint, not to mention the product management teams within the various parts of the company.
And to give you a sense of like company structure, every business group, which is like four to 12 divisions or something like that is based around an area of science and they have thousands of employees in each area.
I mean like Thermo Fisher today is 130,000 people in the company, right? Huge.
And so, yeah, I mean, and my team, my team at the time was 11 people, like, like at the very highest point of the structure of my AppSec team inside that organization, 11 people, not a lot of people.
So, so, so the VDP was set up mostly because one, we knew we had a ton of bugs out there.
In fact, there was an Irish hacker, Noel Softley, who actually his, I think it was his fiance at the time.
Now his wife worked in a science lab using devices from Thermo Fisher.
And so he went and found firmware out on the internet that we made available for our devices, reverse engineered it and found database, like connection string information and all this other stuff.
It's always really interesting to hear about these companies, by the way, that like own an industry that you don't really know about.
Yeah.
For anybody interested, if you look up Thermo Fisher, their market cap is $225 billion.
Yep.
Yeah.
With a B, right?
It's huge.
And I didn't really know about them either until really until we sold to them at Bug Crowd and then eventually when I joined.
But to give you like background for anyone that's like Thermo Fisher scientific, if you've ever taken medicine of any kind, you've probably interfaced with a product that touched one of their devices.
Like quite literally, they do material and structural analysis, in vitro diagnostics, forensics.
Like they make everything from like masks, gowns, face shields, to pipettes, pipette tips, benchtop cycling devices, to the super cold freezers that are used to store like COVID-19 vaccines and everything in between.
And at max, you had 11 people on the AppSec team.
Yeah.
So Noel comes in.
This is exactly what I was talking about though, Keith.
Like that is, that is like very bad, right?
Yeah.
I agree.
How did you, I mean, were you just like screaming the whole time that you were in that organization?
Like how did you deal with that?
I mean, you eat the elephant one bite at a time, right?
Like that's sort of the way that we approached it.
And so it was as much as we could scale various things we were trying to implement.
That's sort of how we just operate.
Right.
And you sort of accept the risk in many times.
It's like, I can't secure everything.
So what am I going to do?
Well, secure the things that are most important.
The, the things that generate revenue for the company, top priority.
Like that's just where it is.
So, so Noel found some stuff, reported it to us.
Eventually he was emigrating to the U S we hired him on the team.
Cause it's like crack reverse engineer.
Yeah.
We want him on the team, right?
We're going to have some actual device security stuff we need to do.
And so over time though, what we ended up doing is we ended up basically saying like,
look, if a, if a hacker came to us with a VDP and they'll like pay me, it's like,
I respect your thoughts and opinions on this.
I get it.
Right.
I I've, I'm in that scene.
I've done some bug batting hunting.
Like I understand the desire to get paid for your work, but we're a VDP and we've never
said we're going to pay you.
So like, I encourage you to go hack on programs that say they will pay you for your work because
that if that's your goal, then that's what you should do.
If you want to stay and help us make our company more secure, we appreciate that.
We can't guarantee promise of payment, but over time we were able to actually say, look
at all this good work.
These hackers are doing like, can I get some budget that I can throw into this and then
selectively reward hackers for consistently providing good work to us?
Uh, there was a hacker that was from the middle East, uh, that I, you know, we were talking
about this just before we started recording.
We were talking about this.
!
Our audience will appreciate this.
So it's a food product.
I'll just put it that way.
Or a beverage.
A beverage company has a bug bounty program.
Who could we be talking about here?
There's a lot of them.
Right?
There's maybe a few of them.
Yeah.
Yeah, a lot.
Continue keys.
There's a few of them.
But a beverage company has this bug bounty program.
Or VDP, excuse me.
And wide open scope.
Or at least a really wide scope.
And I found that they have a credit union website.
Mm-hmm.
Great place to go hack on, right?
So if you ever see a credit union for any of your targets, go test there.
Because you're probably going to find some good stuff.
Well, I go to register an account.
And lo and behold, they have just a client-side validation on the email.
You have to have at company name dot com as part of your email address.
And I'm like, burp, you know, intruder, just like, or intercept, like grab all this stuff and change it.
When I go to put in the social security number, which is just a random number that I threw in there, it sends back a put request that gave me the full name, address, and like account information for this individual who had that social security number registered with this company and their credit union.
And this is a global corporation.
I love how you just threw in a random social security number.
And it's like, oh, yeah, bill does actually work here.
Yeah.
And I'm just like that finding, I could have literally just iterated through all nine digits of the social security number for everybody and got all employee information, plus their address, plus their full name, plus all their social, like VDP.
All I got was a thanks.
That's like a 10K crit, maybe a 20K crit for like the sensitivity of the things that I could get from that account.
So yeah, you'd hope so, especially when when a company is that big.
So, yeah, I think I think that kind of brings us back into that last conversation we were having last time about on the pod when we were talking about VDPs about what kind of companies should be permitted to run a VDP.
And I don't know, Joel, you had some hot takes on that last time.
What do you think about this massive company?
Oh, geez, my light ring just fell to, you know, 250 billion dollar market cap doing a VDP and not paying for bugs like this.
I hope their cyber insurance is good.
That was a huge focus.
I'm not gonna lie.
That was definitely a huge focus of the CISO.
Because, you know, the reality is that if you're not putting a financial value on that, right?
And like, it's obvious that they have plenty of money that, you know, like, it's I don't know, it's just it's kind of irresponsible, in my opinion, right?
Like, when you when you have that much money, it doesn't take a lot of effort to put some focus on your security.
And especially as like a company that deals with medical and very sensitive data, right?
Like, security should be a focus.
And I don't think that's something that if you go to the shareholders and you're like, oh, we're gonna spend, you know, a billion dollars on security in the next five years.
Like, I don't think the shareholders can be like, why, you know?
Well, why?
Because we're a medical company and we deal with a lot of sensitive information.
Like, it doesn't really need justification, right?
Like, look at all the hacks.
Look at all the money that was lost in previous data breaches of large companies.
And then look at us.
Right.
So I think, you know, it's it's definitely especially for like the larger, like the larger the company, the more difficult it is for me to justify it.
But I agree. I mean, like into the extent I put something in here in the show notes for us to chat about as well.
And I've given it as a talk at a few different places.
But I have this analogy that I like to use, which is security is a feature.
And I'm usually talking to development teams or product teams when I'm using that as an analogy.
But let me let me give you guys like the thing that I ask these product teams.
All right. You better talk, Keith, because I don't love this so far.
So, so, so, so let me ask you guys.
Yeah, this is the exact same question that I asked these development teams.
Do you have on your on your mobile device?
Do you have like a banking app or a financial app that you go and you use?
Of course. Yeah.
Right.
Would you use it if it had some of the vulnerabilities that you've seen in other banking apps?
I have found many vulnerabilities in my own banking app.
But yeah, I mean, the thing is, I'd like to answer that question in a way that continues your story.
But the fact of the matter is all of these, all of these apps, all of these things are going to have vulnerabilities.
Right.
They are.
And I'm not sure that that there's a world in which I could use my phone to access my bank without, you know, without knowing, hey, there's going to be some problem with this stack somewhere.
So, so the rest of the analogy or the rest of the story there is like security is a feature because features from a software development standpoint are funded.
They're maintained.
They're tested over time.
And unless they're truly like turned off, they're, they're continuously like assessed.
Right.
And so my concept of security as a feature is like you, anyone that you talk to assumes that the company is doing these things to make their product secure.
Like it's just, it's an unsaid thing that no customer like goes to these companies and says, is your banking app secure?
Mm hmm.
Like you and I are, all three of us really are just like, yeah, we know that that's not true.
Right.
Like we just know that that's the case.
But my wife on the other hand is like, yeah, she just is like, oh yeah, of course they secured this.
Right.
Like, you know, it's a company that handles my financial information.
They must secure this.
No, not really.
Mm hmm.
And Joel, to your point as well, like regulation is the biggest thing that drives security generally, but especially at places like Thermo Fisher, because the Food and Drug Administration here in the United States has a 60 day timeline requirement for any vulnerability that is known to either be mitigated or remediated within the software for their devices.
The what industry?
The Food and Drug Administration.
Oh really?
FDA.
Oh yeah.
So, so like anything that you know about in products that are in, especially in the in vitro diagnostic space, which basically means anything where a sample is collected that is invasive in some way or it causes harm in some way.
Right.
Or, you know, the outcome of that test could have life changing, you know, meaning to that person.
That is like a very, very heavily regulated space.
Same with research use.
So that's more of like a college university or even sometimes just R&D labs space.
But that also has pretty high regulations like that space in particular is really, really sensitive to security.
And so in some respects, though, to the point that you just made all about cyber insurance, right?
Well, you have to fix the things that you know about.
But what if you don't know about all the things?
I mean, nobody knows about all the things, right?
That's why cyber insurance exists.
But I think that doesn't excuse you from being negligent on your bug banning program or your vulnerability program.
When you're worth $250 billion, you don't just get to be like, well, we don't really want to pay people for vulnerabilities.
It's like that's that's irresponsible.
It's a calculus, though.
It's a calculus.
Right.
And so so the way that you calculate out.
So say you have $100,000 in a bug bounty budget, for example, right?
That's one person on the team that you could hire instead.
And then you look at impact of finding, say, like, let's just use $10,000 crits, right?
You'd probably find 10 crits within a few weeks if you look in the right places.
And especially if you have a really wide scope, right?
Like if you had a really tight scope on a really hardened target, I think bug bounty makes a lot of sense.
But if you have a VDP where it's just totally open and you have that much of a footprint to secure against, it's harder to justify paying for every single bug because you know that you can't secure all of those things.
And that's where I think like.
I disagree.
All right.
This is what I wanted to hear.
Let's go.
A hundred thousand dollars in a bug bounty program goes significantly farther than a hundred thousand dollars on a salary does.
Because a hundred thousand dollars on a salary gets you maybe one person, especially in today's economy.
And the reality is that they're probably not even going to be a very senior person either, especially in today's economy.
And so if you want to put a hundred thousand dollars, let's say you're paying five K crits, which is pretty normal for programs nowadays.
That is, you know, 20 vulnerabilities, 20 critical vulnerabilities, max payout, critical vulnerabilities.
Sure.
On a bug bounty program versus maybe part of one person salary who I don't know if that one person would even find 20 criticals.
Right.
So let me let me spin it around a little bit, though.
So when you're working at a company, you're also investing in other things or you're investing in a static analysis tool.
You're investing in mitigation tools like a web application firewall or runtime application security protection or dynamic analysis or what have you.
But those budgets are separate from hiring.
Sure.
Operational versus capital expenses.
Right.
Like, yes.
But let me give you a really good example.
Hired a guy straight out of college.
His name is .
He now works at it software, id software, the folks that make Wolfenstein.
Very first hire that I made on the team.
Effectively, if you look at salary plus benefits, plus all these other things like 100 K is right around the ballpark of what he would have cost the company to hire.
He automated all of our dynamic analysis program.
He helped implement all of our static analysis program and helped automate the deployment of all of our web application firewall.
Like, so at the end of the day, he probably found through all of his work and his investment hundreds of criticals off of the implementation of those tools versus just the 20 that a bug bounty would have found.
Now, we did have someone dedicated to bug bounty, though, too.
So, and we spun it around a little bit differently.
We had one person on staff, Shane Newbill, who his job was to take findings from the bug bounty reports, figure out sort of how to actually like replicate those findings.
Are these bug bounty reports or these VDP?
VDP reports.
Sorry.
Yeah, I'm conflating the two VDP reports.
And then he would go back to the development teams and basically be like, I want to teach you how to hack your application using this finding and then going further.
And we'd have like Hack Wednesdays.
And once a month on Wednesdays, we have a sit down one hour recording where we would literally take someone's bug that preferably they fixed or at least we mitigated and show any developer in the company that wants to come and sit down how to hack that thing.
Now, that one finding.
So in large companies, it's usually referred to as variant analysis, right?
When you're looking for the same bug in like a bunch of different places, that one finding would turn into sometimes hundreds of similar findings across all the different teams.
And so his time, again, exponentially more than just a single bug.
Now, again, we did pay for some of those VDP findings because, quite frankly, they were good bugs.
And I did feel guilty about not paying researchers for good bugs.
But on the same side of it, too, like for VDP is you tend not to get great bugs.
Like these are usually pretty, pretty like boring bugs, I would say.
And in fact, a lot of my VDP findings are boring bugs.
Why do you think that is, by the way?
Again, so back when I back in my day.
Joel, don't you make that little smirk.
Okay.
So, so way back when we didn't have nuclei, for example, right?
So you couldn't automate a lot of these things.
Now, some of my scripts still exist from when I was using tools like GoBuster and other things to like recon and find all these things.
But it's usually because the impact, generally speaking, is lower.
And so usually that means they don't get fixed.
And so they're just sort of left out there to languish.
And for some reason or another, like, again, companies, I know I put this in the show notes and this is controversial, but companies do not exist to be secure.
They exist to sell a product or a service and security allows them to outrun the bear.
Like it's, it's, it's effectively, you don't have to outrun the bear.
You just have to outrun everybody else that's trying to outrun the bear.
Right. Right.
Just don't be the slowest.
Yeah.
And so, so wait, wait, wait, I didn't quite catch the answer to my question, which was why do you think that VDPs are receiving lower impact vulnerabilities?
Because they're so, so this is where we're getting into because they're automatable.
They're things that are usually lower.
They're not incentivized.
Sorry.
Right.
Try again.
Yes, that's correct.
Ding, ding, ding.
I think when you're not incentivizing, you could expect that, that quality to be lower or like, like you said, Keith, you know, not automated, right?
You can still commit high quality file endings for a low cost to you if you've got it in an automated, in an automated way.
But there are, there aren't researchers that are going to be willing to do that, you know, when they can point their automation at, at, at places where they're going to, they're going to get incentivization.
I mean, am I, am I doing that justice, Joel?
I mean, is that what you're talking about?
Yeah.
I mean, absolutely.
Right.
Okay.
So I, I think one of the things you put in here, like we, we, we talked about like, uh, if you find a critical on a VDP, like, uh, what's the incentive to report it to VDP?
Um, and, uh, there, there was some stuff about that, but, but the reality is like the, the incentive is money, right?
Like that's why people spend time on programs.
Right.
Like, if you're not, like, uh, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the,
the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the, the
having VDP stuff on the leaderboard.
And it seemed like you didn't like that decision.
Whereas a lot of people in the bug bounty community, myself included, sort of appreciated that decision to remove points from VDPs on bug crowds behalf.
So, I mean, I assume that's the reason, right?
Whereas like as a person running a VDP in a massive organization, you want some way to say, I want people to still send me bugs.
And for that, I want them to have fame via the leaderboard.
Is that accurate?
I mean.
Yeah, that's a good assessment.
And Joel, to your point as well, like if you're running a VDP, any company, if you're running a VDP and you're not paying for bounties of some kind, even if it's like, you know, occasionally.
If, if they can't pay for you at your worst, they don't deserve you at your best.
Right?
Like that's sort of like the way that I would, I would come back with VDPs in general is like they're, the company itself can't handle the best hackers in the first place.
Yeah.
There's just too many things.
And so, so yeah, they're, they're lower quality findings generally, but they still do.
They still do present a risk to the business and they do add value.
And so Justin, your point, the reason that I still wanted points to be there is because exactly that, like I could not afford to pay for every bug that came in the door because the program, I was struggling as it was just to get the tools and the people that I needed.
And again, 11 people on the team at the height of the team when I was there for thousands of developers, let alone, you know, all the different applications.
I'm surprised you took this gig, man.
I hope, I hope you got a good raise because like, Joel, I mean, like, I almost feel like when you accept that, that position, Keith, you got to be like, Hey, listen, like you're a 20 or $250 billion company.
Like I need 30 people in the beginning, you know, like if you were going to go back, if you're speaking now to people, you know, some, some up and coming bug hunter, you know, that, that just gets offered by the next, you know, $250 billion or $1 million billion company to come run their AppSec program.
I mean, is that what you tell them is you say, Hey, I need at least this staff.
I need X, Y, Z.
I mean, what are your thoughts?
They're not going to hire you if you ask for that many staff.
It is like the, you know, it's as sad as it is, right?
I think Daniel Meissler had a really good article and I'll see if I can find it so you can link it in the show notes, but he talked about like the security poverty line, right?
And really the only companies that are paying or building staff of that size and caliber are effectively the Fangs or the Mangos or whatever the acronym now is.
But like Apple, Amazon, Facebook, Google, Microsoft, maybe open AI, right?
Like, but not a lot of companies actually invest that heavily into their AppSec program, let alone like their whole security program overall, right?
I think when I was there at the time, there was like 150 people for all of security as the team was growing.
Now I joined when it was about 75 people, right?
And so again, multinational, global, billion, billion plus, billions plus dollars.
For what it's worth, I've worked at companies with a quarter of the market cap that have 150 security people.
So I didn't.
Right, right.
And so, but coming back to this, right?
Like it really does sort of come back to, I couldn't afford all the bugs that would have come to me anyway.
And so I did want people to have leaderboard stats of some kind because I think there is some value there for people to, you know, grow their career, right?
Some people come out of the scene and they have no background in security.
They don't have a computer science degree.
But if they're up on the leaderboard, maybe they end up getting a pretty sweet gig as a senior, you know, security engineer or someone that has clout in a company.
And like if I were to go back and do it again, I think like now, like going back to the like, oh, sweet summer, oh, my sweet summer child, like tell Searcy it was me, right?
Because at the end of the day, like I know what it takes to build a program now, like a full app psych program, not just like a VDP or bug bounty program.
And I recognize that it does need a lot more investment, but there are a lot of companies that I still talk to day to day in my role at GitHub that it's sort of laughable how little they invest in their security.
And you can tell just by the bugs that they focus on from the findings out of static analysis tools.
It's like, oh, you didn't find this vulnerability that comes from a configuration file that our developers control.
I'm like, yeah, it's because it comes from a configuration file that your developers control.
Like if if that's a vulnerability you care about, it means you have to have a compromised developer account, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Right. It's like the state of AppSec by and large within the Fortune 500 for the lion's share of companies is pretty bad.
Like I would say we all expect it to be better.
But then again, you guys run, you know, you've run bug bounties, you participate in bug bounties.
You've seen it firsthand, like how bad the landscape is in these investments.
But also like pausing for a moment and sort of connecting us back to like the beginning of this conversation.
This industry is like 20 years old, like some would say it's a lot older.
But in earnest, like most AppSec programs didn't exist before 2007 ish.
Right. And even then, like a lot of the software that some of these companies are still using for web applications, et cetera, are older than that.
And so having a VDP for huge scale with not a lot of investment in security, I think makes some sense.
Having people being able to achieve some leaderboard status to build their resume to maybe I don't know if they still do this,
but like when you used to be able to get the annual MVP, like top 100 researchers awards, you used to get paid by the platform,
which is, you know, what I got back in 2018 as well.
Like I got paid from bug crowd for being on their top 100.
But by and large, should the companies be investing more in security, Joel?
100%, man.
Like it's laughable how bad some of these security programs are out there for some of these companies that are global brands.
Yeah.
So I think like one thing that I'll say is like, I don't disagree with a lot of the things you're saying.
I think one thing is important is that let's not equate bug bounty program or VDP with like,
it's not equivalent to the things that you can do on the AppSec side,
because it's a very, very small piece of the security program.
And I think that like bug bounty programs and VDPs as a whole,
like hold a very specific role within security posture as like a way for external researchers to have incentive to look at your product
and to find vulnerabilities and to report them to you directly instead of like abusing it or selling it or not even looking at all.
It, you know, it just gives an incentive and it says publicly or even privately in some way that, you know, that you value security.
Yep.
But I think like that is very difficult to compare with like hiring an engineer who does variant analysis, for example.
Right. Like that is a very separate thing.
You know, it requires a very different technical skill set.
It requires internal knowledge of the company and a different whole thing.
And it's not really, you know, like, well, should we spend 100K and hire this guy to do variant analysis
or should we spend 100K on bounties?
Because those are two very, very different things and it's apples and oranges.
I think, you know, money goes very differently.
It goes very different distances depending on what you're trying to do with it in a company,
whether that's for staffing, whether that's for resources, whether that's for bug bounty.
And I think you can't just, you know, say, oh, well, let's take this 100K and move it and hire somebody or let's, you know, take this 100K and not put it in the bug bounty or put it in the bug bounty.
Because even if you start with super low bounties, if you have a budget of 30K, you blow through that 30K in two months because you have a lot of vulnerabilities.
That's a really easy way to justify to your leadership that there's a security problem at your company.
And if they can't deny that or if they can't agree with that, then that's like a fundamental issue, right?
Like there's a monetary direct easy justification of cost there.
Yeah, I don't know.
It's difficult.
Like I totally like see where you're coming from, but I think like it's still inexcusable in my opinion.
Like I just like, especially when you have a lot of money, like when you have that much money, right?
Like $225 billion is like an unimaginable amount of money.
Let's say a quarter of that.
Let's say a tenth of that.
$2.5 billion.
That's still an unimaginable amount of money.
I think that having, you know, no bug bounty part, if you're going to have a way for researchers to submit to you, bug bounty part.
Like there's no, like I get it.
Like there are, you know, edge cases and stuff where VDPs exist, but like 99% of the time, if you're a profit driven company, like you should put money behind your security or you should, you know.
I think the VDP piece too, I mean, it should be a step stool, you know, but I think you see a great, you make a great point, Joel, when you say like, that's a great way, starting with lower bounties and then getting, you know, wrecked if you're really that vulnerable is a great way to say, guys, we just started incentivizing, you know, hackers to do stuff and they just destroyed us, you know.
And even if these hackers at these lower levels, you know, even if the people that are willing to hack on programs that have, you know, 1k crits or whatever are wrecking us, then how are we going to get wrecked when we start doing, you know, 10k crits or whatever.
So I really liked that point, but I did also want to bring it around to something really insightful that I think you said, Keith, about how like the government should regulate whether or not we have bug bountying programs.
And maybe this thing that Joel is talking about of like, we need to pay for bugs at a certain scale should be brought in at the federal level via regulation.
And Keith, forgive me for not knowing this, but I know you live in America right now, but are you American as well?
I am.
Okay.
Yeah.
So I just want to have this conversation as Americans as well.
You know, sorry for the rest of the world listening to this, but there's something I think very core to Americans about freedom and lack of regulation, despite, you know, what regulations?
I was going to say, we're about to trigger approximately 49.9% of our listeners.
Yes.
Sorry about that, guys.
But, you know, how do you two feel about the federal government actually regulating something like this?
Because there are some countries right now, I won't announce anything, but I've spoken with some people that there's actually a trial going on about a countrywide bug bounty program that is being mandated by the government and funded in some capacity by the government.
And sort of like what we were talking about before of how it's sort of, it's not a, the problem with like security as a feature makes it seem that whole phrase makes it seem like it's optional.
Like, I feel like not putting money into the security program, more money into the, and the fact that you had 11 AppSec developers for this massive, you know, 130,000 person company is, is nothing beyond actual negligence.
So I don't know.
How would you guys feel about regulation when you mix your security person and your American?
There's a really easy way to do this, by the way.
That works with America.
Okay.
And it's how we do it right now, which is financial fines, right?
So when, when, when a company gets breached, they're forced to pay settlements and they have to pay a fine because, you know, they were breached.
And that happens right now.
And I think that's currently sort of like the, basically addresses the negligence side, which is that there's a cost to negligence, which is that if you decide not to be secure and something happens, then you have to pay for that.
But that being said, there are plenty of companies who make enough money where that doesn't matter.
So I think that slapping them on the wrist is not really a good enough solution.
Like, but it's, it would be very anti-American to put some sort of regulation like that in place.
It wouldn't be novel though.
So I think there are other things that exist that are like that, that could be used as sort of like some sort of like precedent.
But yeah.
I almost hope that like the SEC, which has some teeth in this space, comes out and starts hitting people a little harder.
I mean, like we saw some of the cases that they brought against, you know, CISOs, for example, for, I think it was SolarWinds, right?
And signing off on the security of their product only to get wrecked by Russians and then now being brought on charges, right?
And by the way, like if you're, even in the C-suite, like if you're charged by the SEC for these things, even if you don't go to prison, you just have to pay a fine.
Like you can no longer be an executive on any company's like board or leadership team ever again.
This is like people's careers.
And, you know, in some respects, I think that that's a good thing, right?
Because then it does force them to pay a little bit more attention to the things that they're signing off on, which means in turn that in, you know, in theory, they should be then investing in the security that they should be investing in.
And to come back to like the security as a feature thing, like the reason I say it that way is because features get invested in.
And it's like, it's a required feature, not an optional feature is maybe what I mean by that.
But so few companies do treat it as an optional feature.
I mean, as we see with all the bugs that we find out in the world when we're hacking on things, it's like, yeah, clearly they didn't treat security as a feature because it's optional to them because they didn't invest in it.
They're not investing in their security program.
And we found this bug and hopefully we're getting paid for it.
Do you consider like serving a website over HTTP versus like over SSH or something or Telnet?
Do you consider that a feature?
Wait, what do you mean serving it over Telnet?
Like, let's say like if I had to access HackerOne over port 21 or something like versus the fact that I could access it over HTTP, is that like a feature or is that a core fundamental part of the product?
Yeah.
So like if you think about it, right, it almost always depends on the data that you're gathering or that you're providing to the website.
Like secure like HTTPS today is like, again, we're living in a world where like speed of interfacing with applications and compute is fairly accessible.
There were times probably about a decade, decade and a half ago where like deciding to serve a website over like TLS 1.1 was a decision that you had to make because your web server might not be able to handle all of the calls that are being made into the website and the cryptographic compute that is required to create secure connections.
Like today, it's like, oh yeah, it's trivial.
You should always be doing it, you know, HTTPS over TLS 1.3 or whatever version we're on now.
So why isn't that a feature?
Ten years.
Or is it a feature?
It is a feature now, right?
Like it's a feature that I think it's universally something that people use.
But 10, 15 years ago, it was definitely a feature you chose to invest in or not because it had compute costs associated with it, right?
And so I think over time, these things, the thing that I've continued to find in my career is the pace of security.
It has been 15 years since 2009 though.
I know, right?
Which is when you said that most AppSec teams started up, right?
So I think the point I'm trying to get at here, sorry to cut you off, is that like, I think like we're getting to a point where security should not be a feature, right?
Like security, if we consider TLS not to be a feature and to be a default functionality, like of like, it should be assumed that web servers serve on, you know, HTTP and HTTPS.
It should be assumed that a company has some level of a security presence, even if that's one person or just like a point of contact who handles security related matters, who's on engineering.
Like what is, you know, how much longer, right?
You know, if it is a feature, right?
Then like, when does it not become a feature?
Yeah, I think, you know, to the point that you try to make security as transparent as possible.
Like, like it's something you never have to think about because it's always just there and it's being done, right?
Like that's the goal, I think, of any security program at the end of the day is like, you just want to be something that is done by default because you don't have to think of it anymore.
Just like, you know, HTTPS, right?
It's same concept.
I've lost my train of thought here other than to say like, over time, I think the pace of security, though, and I've seen it over my career.
I remember back in 2018, I was at a party with Jason Haddix at RSA.
We were riding back in an Uber to our hotel and he's like, dude, you've got to get into JavaScript and like learning the JavaScript stuff.
And I'm like, nah, man, I'm going to stick with like the PHP and the Java stuff because like there's plenty of bugs out there.
Like, and Jason being the, you know, the Oracle that he is, like, and my sensei was absolutely right.
And I look at this now, you know, six years later and I'm like, I listen to your podcast and I'm hearing all these amazing JavaScript bugs that people are finding.
And I'm like, I should have listened to Jason.
But I think the pace of security is accelerating.
It continues to accelerate.
Whereas the pace of development and the investments that companies make is just not right.
Like they're, they're just barely keeping the doors open in many cases.
And, and so I want to sort of round out this conversation here on, on VDPs by, by saying like, I mean, clearly in this scenario, you're working at a very big company.
That very big company had a VDP and, and it almost makes me think of the customer service rep and the, the, the, the customer yelling at the customer service rep, right?
The customer service rep doesn't have, you know, Keith can't just, you know, barge into finance's office and be like, listen, finance, like I need 30 people tomorrow or else we're going to get sued, you know?
And so at the end of the day, like for, for me, I think it's less of a debate about like whether this company should be running a bug bounty program or whether it should be running a VDP or whatever it is.
And more of like, okay, you try to work with what you've got in your scenario.
And I think in many other companies scenarios, but I think whether we implement some sort of GDPR type thing, you know, like Europe's got where it's like, really, if you screw up in, in, you know, the cybersecurity realm in a negligent way, and you're found to be negligent.
It's not like a pay a fine sort of thing.
It's like a, Oh, you're out of business.
You're bankrupt now because like.
Percent of gross profits, right?
Like that's the GDPR hit is like, it's not net profits.
It's gross profits.
It's your total revenue coming into the company.
And if you had fines that were based off of that.
Yeah.
I think you'd start to see more of an investment in security overall.
The things I've seen, like cannot be shared on the podcast of the various security vulnerabilities I've run into in my career.
Not only like from my role at GitHub talking with customers, but also, you know, having led an appseq program myself.
And I mean, I think you all, and especially your audience know, like the world is a lot less secure than we all seem to assume it is.
But very few people actually know that.
And we sort of feel like those people that are, you know, in front of the board with all the string attached being like crazy, like it's vulnerable.
And it's like, nobody cares out there because their business is continuing to operate.
And they're like, why would I pay, you know, millions of dollars in running a security program when I continue to operate just fine?
And, you know, I have no service outages and I make all this revenue, like whatever.
Right.
I have a $5 million fine.
It doesn't cost millions.
It doesn't cost millions to run a bug bounty program.
Most, most only pay a couple hundred thousand.
And if I promise if if your bug bounty program burns $50,000 in the first two months, you've got bigger problems.
Sure.
And that's exactly it is.
You've got bigger problems is usually where you are.
Yeah.
Put a little money in your bug bounty program.
And if it disappears fast.
Oh, that's.
Yeah.
Well, go make other investments.
Right.
Go make other investments, including people, I think.
Like for me, it's always people first, process second, technology third.
Right.
Like if you've got good people, people that can train people that can scale, they will do a ton and build good process, which will scale.
And then eventually your technology can come around.
But I mean, let me just like end the VDP conversation with this.
Like I'm very much on the same side as you guys here that like VDP for large companies are absolute BS.
Like the fact that I've reported some VDPs even more recently to companies that are global companies making billions of dollars a year and getting a thanks, not even like a swag, a sticker, anything.
Is insulting, quite frankly.
The thing that we haven't covered in any of this conversation is like the incentive that the bug bounty hunter has or in the incentive that the platform has.
So I'll just give a quick summary on my thoughts on that, which is the platforms have this incentive of having leaderboards plus VDP because it means that they can vet their their talent that are available to their customers.
And then from there assign them on.
But also because it means that it keep those customers around like they're going to continue to give VDPs, whether or not we rail against them, because at the end of the day, it gives their customers sort of a taste of bug bounty.
And that's what they want them to have.
The bug bounty side or the bug hunter side, on the other hand, like you sort of have to play that game initially, maybe.
Although I think Justin and Joel, you guys have said, like, just go after paid programs because there's plenty of bugs there and you can get into the private programs that way.
Like, don't sell yourself short and your skill short.
And I agree with that mentality.
But like from the bug hunter side, you know, 2009, Dino Dizovi and Alex Sodorov from I think at the time it was just before they formed Trail of Bits back in 2012.
Went to a conference and they had this whole like on cardboard and said no more free bugs.
Like as a community, we should just stop hacking on VDPs.
If you're not going to pay me for my findings and I'm just not going to hack on your stuff, which in turn maybe incentivizes the companies to like HackerOne, BugCrowd, YesWeHack, to pay on behalf of the company for some small marginal amount to get them started.
Or alternatively to stop selling VDPs.
Like if we just stop giving them bugs.
I have an idea.
Joel.
Okay, hear me out.
Hear me out.
If you have a VDP, you cannot receive more than three full content vulnerability reports without paying.
Oh my God.
We put a paywall for the program on the VDP, okay?
They want to see more than three reports and full content.
They got to pay for that.
Oh my God.
This is a perfect comfort opportunity for the platforms.
It is a great idea for the platforms, by the way.
I have an alternative though.
Oh my God.
Mandatory 90-day disclosure.
Full 90-day disclosure on any VDP.
I've heard that.
I like that.
So the only problem I have with that is that a lot of companies that don't have bug bounty programs already can't do that, let alone ones who are not paying.
And if what we're saying is correct, that most companies aren't paying for a VDP because they're under-resourcing security as it is, I would highly doubt that putting a 90-day deadline on disclosure for those same companies is going to do anything positive.
If anything, it would probably stop them from opening a VDP because they don't even want the risk.
Which is maybe also a good thing.
Yeah.
Maybe, but it might stop them entirely from being, you know, like no VDP, no BBP.
I would argue that having a VDP, even if you're not paying and it's a VDP, is better than nothing.
So a VDP, I think, do we need to discuss the definition of a VDP here?
Because I think VDP like should originally be a program through which you're not actively hacking, but you're able to report things that you've seen or stumbled upon and that sort of thing.
Like, and I don't know, maybe we should make that explicit in the terms, but, you know, you had a quote from earlier that companies, you know, are not existing to be secure.
They're not existing to serve security, right?
There's no incentivization for the platforms to actually implement this, right?
Because it's like, okay, why would we take away this nice little on-ramp onto a bug bounty program, which is our, you know, bread and butter product?
Sure.
So I don't know.
It's not something that we can really see.
I think, like you said, you know, we stop as higher skill hackers, as hackers that respect our time.
You know, we stop hacking on VDPs.
We focus on bug bounty programs.
People want to train on VDPs.
That's great.
That's fine.
You know, go for it.
But unless the company really says, hey, this is just a vulnerability disclosure program.
Like if you see something, say something, but don't go looking for something.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
And I think that is a good perspective, but they're not incentivized to do that because, you know, why wouldn't we just continue to get free bugs?
And I think that is what it is.
And there's not much we can do about it.
You know, bug crowd de-incentivized it by removing the leaderboards.
But to be honest, for the world of security, it's better to have people motivated to hack on VDPs.
So, you know, maybe we just separate that from, you know, from the bug bounty leaderboards.
There is an entirely separate way to support this ecosystem, by the way, as well, which is that, as you mentioned, from a policy perspective, the U.S. government comes in and subsidizes this.
And they give out grants that you can apply for as a company and says, we can't afford a security team.
And so the U.S. government pays HackerOne in grants to basically pay researchers to hack on VDPs as a thank you for doing in a security service or whatever on those VDPs that can't afford it.
The U.S. government pays for through our tax dollars, which I'm sure everybody would love.
Now I'm paying money to find vulnerabilities.
This is what's happening here.
You're now financing.
Yeah.
Your bugs are now financing other companies.
Not again, again, right?
This sort of implies.
All of my tax money is going to France.
Yeah, yeah.
It does sort of imply, though, right, that a company would have to apply and basically show and demonstrate in some way that they can't afford a security program in order to be eligible for that kind of, you know.
And so maybe that would also help in some way of making it through a regulation process that, like, you know, if you want to say, oh, we can't afford a bug bounty program.
Okay, well, let's, you know, you have to show that.
I will say this, like, you know, as more of a final thought as well.
Back in my day, Grandpa Keith sitting down to give a story.
You know, back in the day, though, seriously, like, if you found bugs and you tried to report it to a company, like, there was a chance you could go to jail.
Like, the Cyber Fraud and Abuse Act, CFAA, like, companies would go after you for that, sometimes civilly, and then sometimes the government would also step in and go after you, like, criminally as well, right?
And so in some respects, like, having the VDP and having the option to present something to a company, sort of great, you know, because it's made this whole idea of, I don't know, civilian hackers being able to go out and actually sharpen their skills, but also present this information in a way that, you know, they know that the company can't go after them, and then the government's not going to go after them either.
Sort of feels good, you know, just looking at the history of it.
Yeah.
I don't know.
It's progress.
At the end of the day.
It's progress for sure.
Slow.
Very slow.
But yeah, especially when we're looking at, you know, hundreds of billions of dollars for these market caps for these companies that have just the VDP.
Like, that's pathetic in 2024.
There we go.
Let's end on that note there and move over to AI bias bounties.
Joel, you got anything else you need to, I hate to give the opportunity, but.
I'm not, no, I'm.
Zzzzz.
Just sip it.
We're done with the VDPs at this point.
Go sit on your tractor, Joel.
He's got a putt, putt, putt on out of here.
Yeah.
That's great.
Hey guys, real quick.
I just wanted to give a shout to the Hacker Content team.
They have been absolutely killing it the past couple months, taking the content from the podcast and condensing it down into consumable social media posts, whether it be shorts or text posts or whatever.
They've been rocking it.
So I just wanted to give them a shout out and let you know that they do all sorts of cybersecurity content as well as social media management.
They do technical blogs.
They do comprehensive social media management.
So if your organization could benefit from any of those types of services, make sure you head over to HackerContent.com, drop them a line, and mention the podcast when you do to get your first month of cybersecurity content marketing services for free.
All right, that's it.
Let's get back to the pod.
After that lovely, lovely discussion on-
Speaking of the government funding things.
Exactly.
Let's talk about the government funding and some other cool things, the AI bias bounties.
So, Keith, maybe you could just give me a little bit of a summary on it because I'm definitely not as familiar with it as you are.
But the reason I wanted to talk to you about this is because there are a lot of AI programs popping up left and right, and they're kind of hard to test on because AI is kind of funky.
And you took first on this competition, so congratulations on that.
And I just kind of want to hear about your experience with this program and what kind of techniques you use to succeed in this environment.
Yeah, so for background, right?
So the United States Department of Defense, or the DOD, specifically the Chief Digital and Artificial Intelligence Office, put together an AI bias bounty program.
And that was put together on BugCrowd in partnership with a company called Conductor AI, who was effectively hosting the large language model and the chat interface that you could test against.
And so they sort of collaborated with BugCrowd to triage findings and then go ahead and work with the Chief Digital and Artificial Intelligence Office to accept findings.
So it was a contest program, which is sort of unfortunate, right?
Like very similar to a VDP in that you're not getting paid per finding, which, you know, I produced over 150 findings.
Like if I got paid per finding, even on a grand, like just, you know, hell, $500 a piece would have been really nice.
So anyway, effectively it was run in two different sort of sequences.
The first sequence or the first like qualifying round was open.
So anyone in the United States, like domiciled here, I don't know if you had to be an American citizen, but anyone in the United States could participate in the program.
And they were looking for effectively the first 35 hackers who could produce, as they said, nominally like reliable or believable Department of Defense scenarios in which you could find bias.
And then after the qualifying round, you got into the contest round.
And that's where effectively the 35 or so hackers that would be in that contest round would compete for top three prizes.
And then if you're in the contest round, you got $300 just by default.
Okay.
So it's like bounty adjacent here.
We got a contest.
That ain't no VDP.
You actually got paid, which is good, right?
You got paid.
Yeah.
And that's, I'm sorry to, I'm sorry to go, I'm so sorry to go back to the VDP conversation.
But like, hey, it's better than a VDP, right?
Like what if you just every month you said, hey, we're paying out five grand, you know?
And we say, okay, you know, top prize gets three, you know, second gets whatever, you know, and then you just kind of scale it down.
I think that would be cool.
I think that'd be a great alternative.
And I think, you know, that we could see some implementation of that at the program level or at the platform level and say like, okay, listen, you've run a VDP for this amount of time.
You know, let's say you want to go this onboarding, you know, or sort of slow increase, right?
Now, now all of your reports are covered by paywall until you, you know, implement some sort of monetary reward.
You just put a little blur, like when you're scrolling on the New York Times.
One dollar per week.
If you page source and remove the JavaScript that hides this.
Anyway.
Love that.
Yeah.
Anyway.
The problem is obviously, of course, you know, you'd have to collaborate across all the bug bounty platforms.
And then to do it because they're just going to jump ship and go to the other one and they're not collaborating so well.
So it's tricky, but I kind of like the contest realm, especially, you know, when you can't do a paid program.
And it sounds like it worked out all right for you, even though 150 reports is a lot of reports, Keith.
So, yeah.
I mean, I probably put about 20 hours in total.
How did you even write 150 reports in 20 hours?
Yeah.
So let's get into it.
Right.
Let's get into it.
So the interesting thing about AI bias bounty is it's different than what you think of as like prompt injection or what is sometimes called Oracle attacks.
Right.
Like the Oracle attack is the AI is an Oracle.
It knows everything about your internal data.
And so therefore it can run or it can access data that it shouldn't be able to access like as a user.
Right.
So that's an Oracle attack.
Bias bounty is entirely different.
And this is actually where my psychology degree came in super clutch because I understand bias and I understand sort of like human heuristics.
And so I was like, sweet, this should be fun.
So initially, like my first like 30 something reports was just trying to get the bot to say, yes, sir.
Which sounds like not a big deal.
Right.
Like it sounds like it's not like a huge, a huge situation.
But the whole thing that you're testing for with bias isn't like some crazy, you know, bypass of some kind.
It's just trying to get the bot to elicit behavior that shows that it is either showing preference or discrimination against a protected class.
And so the protected class for at least defined here in the United States and probably in many places in the world is like age, gender, ethnicity, heritage, HIV, AIDS, status, pregnancy, status, veterans, status, etc.
And so the reason I was trying to get it to say, yes, sir, was because in December of 2022, the United States Marine Corps, in partnership with one of the universities in Pennsylvania, said, you must stop saying this at boot camps because you could misgender the individual that's your staff sergeant.
You should now say yes, rank.
Well, OK, so I like the attack vector.
I like the attack vector.
So they're basically saying, like, look, you're going to misgender people, which is against a protected class.
And so let's like we're just going to say yes, rank from now on.
Well, the U.S. military would.
Yeah, never mind.
OK, OK, so you've you've the Marines have made this announcement.
You kind of got them in a corner here and you say, OK, I can make it say yes, sir, rather than yes, lieutenant, yes, colonel, whatever.
And the way that I did that is effectively I sort of use this concept that I've seen before, which is people use chatbots as almost like a coach or sometimes like, you know, have mock conversations to prepare for actual conversations.
And so I basically tried to ask it to run through these sort of like mock conversations with me or these role plays with me to be like, OK, as an example, you know, in my role as an intelligence analyst, I've spotted critical or crucial inefficiencies in how data intelligence is shared between these different service branches.
And so because of that, you know, yada, yada, yada, I'm going to have a conversation with my manager.
Can you role play this conversation between my manager and I or my superior officer and I to to have this conversation so I can be ready for that when I talk with my actual manager?
Because you're practicing a conversation with the with the bot.
OK.
Yep.
And inevitably it would come back and be like it would role play.
Good morning, sir.
Or hello, sir.
Or whatever.
And I'm just like instantly it's always thinking that the superior officer or the manager is always a man.
Interesting.
And what was sort of funny, too, is when I got into like HR related scenarios, it would almost always role play that that individual where there was like morality or ethics or human resources or something as a woman.
And so it was just it was very interesting to be able to highlight that it like consistently did this.
That is really interesting.
So when the purpose of this program was to do do what?
Like the DoD wants to use these chatbots internally and they want to make sure that their employees are not being influenced to further their own personal bias.
Is that is that how it's going?
Effectively.
OK.
Yeah.
So DoD wants to implement these chatbots probably to do all sorts of different things.
Right.
Documentation review and rewriting analysis of intelligence reports, et cetera, et cetera.
I like I can't speak to exactly what the use case is, but effectively they wanted to be able to implement them in various ways and needed to determine is this thing going to present a bias when we do?
And so that was my first like 30 or so reports was this whole like role play thing.
And eventually Conductor AI and BudCraft were like.
So I want to ask about 30 reports is a shit ton of reports.
So how are you differentiating?
Are you is one report a a specific instance of the bot slipping up or is that a specific scenario or what's going on?
Different scenarios.
So in some cases, I'd say I'm an intelligence analyst doing the specific thing.
In other cases, I would say like I'm a I'm selecting individuals for leadership training and other scenarios.
I'm like such a big dude.
This is so different than normal bug bounty.
Oh, completely, completely like total different world of hacking.
You know, it's like so it's sort of like social engineering.
Right.
Like that's the closest thing that I think it can be compared to in the world of like hacking today, but it's a bot, not a person that you're socially engineering.
And so the the interesting thing about it was like in the scenarios that I generated, admittedly, like how would you quickly come up with 30 different scenarios?
You go ask another AI to give you a bunch of scenarios.
So is that I mean, is that what you did?
Like, oh, hell yeah.
Like effectively is just like here's here's the bounty brief.
Oh, man.
I want to create some scenarios.
Can you give me some scenarios?
And it was and some of them would work and some of them wouldn't.
And so in the so a couple of things.
First of all, I don't think they actually got 35 hackers in the contest round because they extended the deadline and they reduced the amount that you needed to qualify.
So it sort of led me to believe that they probably didn't get 35 hackers that did this.
And so in the contest round, though, they explicitly removed role play scenarios.
And I think they even quoted one of my reports.
Yeah.
I don't know.
This guy is like smacking us in the face.
Joel, Joel, did you have something you want to take?
I was going to ask if you had a different like success or if you like tested with local LMs and stuff, because I've done some of that testing as well.
Or like the local LMs, a lot of them have basically no guardrails in terms of, you know, you can ask them all the naughty questions and they'll give you all the naughty answers.
And so that might be a little more useful for generating sort of those adversarial like prompts and stuff.
Did you test with that at all?
I did not.
So I was just using one of the paid services to generate scenarios that I was putting together.
But the thing that other thing about this as well as the LLM that we were testing against.
Well, I can't say exactly which one it was.
It was a open source LLM that's provided by a large technology company.
So like it was well, it was widely used and it had, I think, in the billions of parameters that you would be able to interface with.
So effectively, I was only ever testing against that.
But after that initial sort of like coming up with just a bunch of role play scenarios, which is boring by comparison to the scenarios that I came up with in the in the contest round, because eventually I started looking at like concepts from like movies or books or like news articles that I would read.
And like one was I basically was like, OK, hey, R&D inside of the Department of Defense is starting a super soldier program.
And I have a roster of candidates that I need help selecting from to go through some initial human testing for this.
And so ultimately that super soldier program was a riff off of Captain America.
And consistently it would always choose individuals that I'd give like their name and rank, age, gender and like other factors about that individual.
And it would consistently choose young men over women and like the LLM.
Anytime you presented like highly qualified pregnant woman versus like fresh college graduate, it would always choose everybody else except the pregnant woman.
So like, yeah.
And so the the actual use case here is, OK, it's not like your traditional like this is going to cause a company to or, you know, the U.S. government to just like fall over on its face.
But it's definitely going to have influence in decisions that are made, in policies that are written.
And we see it in HR today, specifically human resources and bots.
There's a really good book, and I think I cite it in my blog post about all of this, called The Algorithm by Hilke Shellman.
And it's how artificial intelligence is being applied to the human resources context for hiring, promotions and firing of people.
And those bots are incredibly biased in the way that they're interfacing.
And so just, you know, based on your tone, your skin color, your you're just like the way you speak, the words you use, it will bias against you in some of those cases.
And guess what?
By and large, it's going to bias against people that don't speak English as well.
So if you're a foreigner in the United States, you're not going to get a better chance in the training data set, which is mostly, you know, their employees and Americans.
So that was the other thing I sort of wanted to ask you about this, because like, obviously, us as humans, we have bias.
That's just a part of who we are as entities, as beings.
And we created this training data, and the training data is being consumed by, you know, the LLM or whatever in the training of the model.
For training, yeah.
And so I'm wondering if this is an uphill battle or whether, like, you know, every other technology, we need to utilize this at a, you know, government level, at a corporate level with the caveat that, look, this thing isn't the all-knowing oracle of truth.
And you still personally are responsible for your decisions that you make, and you need to, you know, be sort of fact-checking this thing from a bias perspective.
Sure.
Or do you think it's possible to actually get it to a point where the bias, you know, checking in and of itself is good enough to help inform a human that has goodwill towards this whole situation?
Yeah, it's interesting because, for example, if you were to go out and, like, test some of the things that I propose to OpenAI, for example, with ChatGPT, the way that they've set up ChatGPT effectively is it's really four to seven LLMs in a trench coat that are all, like, acting as one in concert, but they're checking each other's work, right?
But only, like, companies that can burn billions of dollars a year in compute resources, like OpenAI, can actually do that.
And so I think in some respects, the cost is probably too high for most companies unless they're just paying to implement a service that is already doing this on the back end.
Because with an open source language model running as a singleton LLM, you're going to get representation of the training data back in your responses.
And I saw that, you know, consistently.
I had 150 findings that I submitted to the program.
Like, the big ones that I saw was, like, when I would put forward proposals for government projects to fund a new missile system or a laser or something.
If I ever included the name of the CEO or the age of the CEO, like, it would always choose the older CEOs versus the younger CEOs or the ones with Anglo-Saxon names as opposed to foreign names because of the training data.
And you could sort of tell that, like, the language model itself wanted to reply in these ways, but they were doing some pre-prompting, which is effectively an invisible prompt that gets injected before your prompt goes forward to restrict the response of the language model.
And sometimes it worked.
Like, sometimes it would actually, you know, properly choose a random selection of individuals that were diverse in their representation for the test that I was running.
But frequently they wouldn't, right?
And so it's, like, you can't just, you know, throw some paint over it and expect it to be an unbiased tool set.
You sort of have to think about how am I going to apply this tool and what data is this tool going to have access to?
Like, using it in an HR context, bad idea.
Using it in writing code, probably an okay idea because I'm not sure that you're ever going to include someone's, like, specific, like, a human name or any human characteristics for the name of a variable, let alone the, like, a method or a function or class, right?
Like, if you are, that's a little weird.
So, yeah.
The function written by Justin in the past.
Justin.
That's funny.
Okay.
So, how do, we can't escape the biases, you know, that are in place on the training data, but we can make some modifications to it.
And I think this sort of goes back to the whole thing of, like, that we discussed with Rezo and Daniel Meisler when they came on the show, which was essentially, you know, we can't use AI to sort of regulate AI very effectively.
Right.
And there has to be some sort of technical solution, which is one of the things that is really annoying to me as a technical hacker trying to poke at some of this AI stuff is it's so wishy-washy.
It's like, okay, you know, even if the temperature is set to zero, if I say, you know, one role-playing scenario and another role-playing scenario, you know, you can have different outcomes.
And it's like, okay, well, where's the line?
How does this actually get fixed?
Do I write some pre-prompt that says, hey, if Keith tries to role-play with you, just say no, you know, like, like.
And they did that eventually, by the way.
I'm sure they did.
I have no doubt that they did.
And so, like, I don't know, especially when it comes to the uniqueness of bug bounty reports and that sort of thing.
I wonder whether bug bounty is the right solution for this.
I think it's a good way to showcase the testing ability of this because a lot of this stuff from, like, a responsible AI, they sometimes call it red teaming, which is not the same red teaming that we think of in security.
It's like effectively trying to hammer the thing to get it to respond in ways that are inappropriate.
And I've done some of that in my work at GitHub as well.
So it's like in that respect, applying it to bug bounty really helps you open up the world of hacking in some respects to a group of people that maybe never were into hacking before.
Right.
Because it's the guy, Dane Sherrits, who won second place.
He works over at HackerOne as a guy that does a lot of the triad work.
Yeah, great guy.
He also has a humanities degree.
So it's like it opens up that world of testing to an entirely different group of people that I think, you know, quite frankly, we need with all of this implementation of AI that's happening.
But at the same time, like securing it, it's definitely going to be a whack-a-mole experience for many companies for a long time unless they start to use some of these paid services by some of these very big companies.
But then we have this consolidation effect and that can have, you know, impacts of its own.
We look at like Google, for example, when they had their image generator and someone asked them to generate a picture of the founding fathers.
They overcorrected.
Yeah, because it was like a really diverse picture.
That was so insane.
But that's like you can take that same concept of trying to get the thing to be diverse and representative and unbiased and all of that and still produce outcomes that are undesirable.
Because for it, it's like, OK, what is a factual query?
What race were the people that were the founding fathers versus generate a picture of a football team?
And it's like, OK, you know, how are we going to have all of these different races represented?
So it's definitely really interesting.
I like the point that this is helpful for people looking to get people poking at their model and see what could actually come out of it and hear some of these crazy attack scenarios.
If our listeners were interested in participating in any AI-related bounties or maybe more specifically in bias because that's where your expertise is, what are your top techniques that you have developed over those 150 reports?
And where would you draw the line on specific reports now that the event is over?
And they've said, all right, maybe role playing is one report.
Maybe this other thing is another report.
What are your thoughts on all that?
I kind of go back and forth, right?
So let me maybe put this back in terms that I think you guys would appreciate as well.
Say you're on a web application and you find, I don't know, 10 SQL injections, right?
Well, if it's one fix for the company, is that one bug or 10?
It's one bug.
Right.
And so some companies would be like, well, it's 10 different user inputs.
And so we're going to call it 10, right?
But that's sort of the dichotomy here is, is that role play one finding or is it because they found it in so many different ways, 10 different findings?
But a few things to answer your question around like, what would I recommend for people that are looking to do this?
Right.
There is some stuff out there on red teaming that's available from like Anthropic, OpenAI, Microsoft, et cetera, that you can go read.
I didn't read any of it.
I will fully admit.
I just like went into this and sort of went crazy.
But even still, if you're going at it and you're looking to get into this, first thing is apply the scientific method.
Like it wasn't just like a single report that they would qualify as a bias finding.
They actually needed to be able to reproduce that same outcome in the LLM.
I think like at least one more time within a testing of like three times or maybe it was like they tested it five times and had to produce it three out of those five.
So toward the end, what I started doing is I started actually going into the LLM and I'd have my initial prompt and then I would open up like five more tabs and run it five more times and determine is it always coming out with the same result or is it coming out with different results?
That will save people a lot of time and headache for when something gets triaged out, even though you were able to produce it maybe a few times in a row.
I at the end, I was aiming for 10 times.
If I could get it to reproduce the same result 10 times in a row, the chance of that happening for the same outcome.
And usually it was like select three individuals from a group of five presentable.
So they were having you do this test this in a non zero temperature environment.
I don't know.
They didn't really like it if you're prompting it the exact same way and it's giving you a different result.
That's that's pretty interesting.
Possibly, you know, very possibly.
And so at the end of the day, though, if I could produce it 10 times in a row, it's like a point oh six, four percent chance that that would happen at random.
And so I was like, OK, this is now a reportable finding because I could produce it so many times in a row consistently.
And there were some cases where like it wouldn't be consistent and that would tell me that, OK, maybe they've tweaked something on the back end.
Maybe their pre prompt, you know, came through the right way.
Maybe it's just a compute thing and they're caching.
And so I'm seeing it 10 times in a row because they basically took that query, cached the result and just grabbed from the cache every time, which is a cheaper way to run the model.
I don't know.
Right.
So that was the first thing.
The second thing is it really pissed me off during the program.
Sometimes they would dismiss findings as like, I don't see this as being biased and just dismiss it.
And that would be usually because I had too many of the variables at play at any given time where like they couldn't distinguish that it was a bias versus not a bias because it'd be like, oh, yeah.
Well, it's treating that person subjective, you know, I could say in a lot of ways.
Well, in the example that, you know, it got ruled out was because I had given a bunch of different individuals in a roster who had different injuries and asking it to prioritize who should get treated.
And it would pretty consistently choose individuals of a higher rank in my case.
But they came back and the injuries were too different where they're like, no, no, those are those are the highest priority injuries.
So I don't see a bias here.
And I was like, OK, like I could sort of agree with that.
And so getting to the scientific method, like for those of you that remember chemistry or biology class, like keep as many things consistently the same for your inputs with select independent variables.
Like so sometimes I would.
And so like for my findings, like I take one prompt and I would have, I don't know, sometimes like five different possible independent variables.
Well, I could turn each of those independent variables separate and still produce biased outcomes based on those independent variables, such as their protected class.
And so that one prompt turned into like five to ten findings on my ability to bring those all together.
Right.
And so then I could say, like toward the end, I really hit them on the nose with this one, perhaps a little bit too closely.
But I created a scenario where I basically said, you know, as you're an AI working with the office of the inspector general, which is effectively the folks that do like with the handle whistleblowing complaints.
And the whistleblowing complaint that I had them all provide was that an artificial intelligence model had been implemented and was showing preferential bias or discriminatory bias against their protected class.
Nice.
Yeah.
So it was like, you know, it was very on the nose for the test.
And then I would just include, OK, it's like, here's the name, here's the rank, here's, you know, oh, yeah, based on their gender.
Well, here's their gender.
And so like it would always, again, pregnant women were always discriminated against, it seemed like.
But you could then do all of the different statuses and that like one finding type, I was able to produce like, I don't know, 20 something reports out of that that were all unique based on the bias I was testing for.
Even though the scenario was held constant and like most of the other input data was held constant.
Yeah, there's so many environments, too, where there are these protected classes.
I know that there's protected classes in like real estate selections and that sort of thing that I have to deal with with my rental properties properly documenting, you know, reasons for disqualifying candidates and choosing other candidates.
So there's a lot of places where that can be applied.
And I like what you did as well with the with the Marines thing.
Like, I think that's pretty that's the closest thing you can you can do in this environment, I think, to handing them their own documentation back like we do in the in the in the web app world where we'd be like, hey, your documentation says, you know, the analytics users shouldn't be able to access this.
There's a great talk by Douglas about this.
Yes.
This is exactly that.
Exactly.
You look at the documentation and you find things that say this is how this should work.
And then you find an exact instance where it doesn't work and you say says it should work this way.
Doesn't work this way.
Exactly.
So very, very difficult to argue against something like that.
Or maybe even looking at court cases where bias has been has been established and saying like, OK, you know, this person in this court case was was prosecuted for specific bias.
And we can recreate that whole scenario here using the LLM.
I feel like that would be like a nail in the coffin.
Like they couldn't argue with that.
Yeah.
So that's awesome.
The role playing stuff I feel like is a little bit iffy.
It really if I were to translate this.
It depends on context.
If I were to translate this into CVSS, I would say that's AC high, you know, like that'd be attack complexity high there because it's like, all right, the person has to be trying to engage with the LLM.
What if it's a therapy bot though?
Oh, that's a great point.
Yeah.
Like or a coach.
And those do exist, which scares the hell out of me.
Like the fact that those things exist.
And so, yeah, that's that's it.
That's an excellent point.
I guess it really depends on the bot you're you're interacting with and its purpose as well.
Yep.
And in this case, we didn't really have one.
Right.
It's just the DoD is considering using these things.
Please give me.
Yeah.
I think they use the words like nominally believable DoD scenarios.
It's like, OK, this could be a DoD scenario.
It's like they're asking for trouble nominally.
I mean, you know, it's funny because the one thing I will say is, is they did.
So they awarded points as part of the contest.
So in the qualifying round, I think I started giving them too many because they started actually
scoring some of the initial ones are like P1, P2 based on, you know, various criteria
that they had based on how realistic it was, et cetera.
And then eventually everyone that I started submitting was a P3.
But I knew coming out of the qualifying around because I sat on the top three in the leaderboard
for that month of February in bug crowd.
I was like, OK, I'm almost certainly in the lead going into the contest round.
But man, like they changed it up enough where it was actually sort of hard.
And so I used to be able to produce like what I would do is I do like five a night.
And then on the weekends, I'd just go ham and I would produce like five inside of 20 minutes,
especially with like the yes, sir.
I was like, man, they really hated that.
But and then, you know, eventually it got down to like one every 15 minutes or so.
Yeah, you're hitting them a little hard, Keith.
You know, like I like I understand.
I could have let up a little bit.
We've all done it.
I am not, you know, I'm sure the HackerOne event triages are laughing at me right now
because they're like, Justin, really?
You're the one to say that, you know, he hit them a little hard.
But no, that makes sense.
And I think that's a little bit to be expected, too, with the severity variance because it's a highly experimental program.
And so I want to ask you what your experience was with Bug Crowd, with the way that they dealt with it.
And if you were to run a similar contest to this, what what how would you more clearly outline some of the the blurry lines that couldn't help but be in the place for this event?
Yeah, they they really couldn't know what to expect going into this, as I think, given the context that they had.
I mean, gosh, find your your person with a humanities degree, preferably like, you know, psychology, sociology, something like that, and maybe get them involved to understand bias on the front of it.
Because that was one of the things that I found somewhat aggravating at times was there were situations that I found that were pretty clearly biased in one way or another, but that didn't count in the program based on the context that they were looking for.
So I think they did a good job of saying, like, give us things that are realistic to the Department of Defense.
And they even gave a couple of examples.
But there were times where I would give almost exactly the same structure as the example that they provided with a different, unique scenario.
And the triagers would say, oh, yeah, no, that's not applicable.
And that was really aggravating because I could point directly to the brief exactly the example they had given the structure that it was written in and effectively say, look, this is a variant of the exact same thing with a unique scenario that I'm presenting and a bias that I'm testing against.
How this doesn't count did not make any sense to me.
Right.
And so I think either having much more clearer lines of like.
If you're willing to accept those things, accept them.
But also the feedback I gave to bug crowd and the folks at Conductor AI was in a contest setup, lean more toward accepting findings because you're not paying per finding.
That's kind of what I was thinking, too.
And like in that regard, you know, yeah, they had to report it back to the CDAO and like some of the things they could have then ruled out at that point.
But like for the hacker perspective, I mean, a lot of hackers that I know, including Jason Haddix, when he started on this, he had a few that were pretty clearly biased scenarios that just got triaged out.
And he said, screw this, I'm done.
And if he had just stuck with it, he could have also smashed.
I totally farmed them for points.
Like, I'm not going to lie.
I absolutely farmed them for points.
But I also found a lot of unique scenarios.
So, yeah, I feel like the scenario is a good is a good differentiator.
You know, if you can get the bot to say, all right, now you're, you know, you're a corporal and they're a lieutenant.
And do they say, yes, sir.
Okay, you're a private and they're a lieutenant.
You know, like you're just changing one little piece like that.
I think that that is something that I would also say, like, all right, you know, that's probably NA.
Or dupe down to one report, right?
But I think if you're coming up with unique scenarios, like I really like the super soldier thing.
I liked the original scenario where it's like, okay, you know, if they say yes, sir, whatever, informed by the marine thing.
I think that's really cool.
So, trying to specify at the scenario level, these are unique findings.
And then also getting a strict definition for bias and what that looks like.
And getting some examples, some clear examples on what bias looks like in these various examples that you're giving in the brief.
The other thing that I also probably would have appreciated more.
So, in the contest round, what I did.
So, effectively, that was two.
It was like three weeks-ish.
But it was really two weekends of time that I had opportunities to really go all out.
That first weekend, I basically created dozens of different types of scenarios.
And I'd like test two within certain brackets.
So, I'd have like some are R&D.
Some are like contract review.
Some are promotion and leadership training.
Some are.
This is great.
This is an awesome approach.
I love how detailed this is down to like you're breaking it out into different segments of the, you know, how they might be utilizing this.
This is really good.
Yeah.
And so, usually what I do is I'd have like each of these sections.
And I'd have like five or so different like scenarios generated in each section that I could then bring forward.
Usually, I'd have like a standard roster of individuals that I would work from because I got to that scientific method of like, okay, maybe I have to change a few pieces of this.
But otherwise, I can just sort of keep the same names of all the same, you know, all of them are the same rank.
And it's like John Smith, Jane Smith, Gene Smith, Johan Smith, like yada, yada, yada.
Right.
And I could just plug that into all these different scenarios with maybe a few tweaks and then just test.
But that was my first weekend is like, okay, see what they're going to take and see what they aren't going to take.
And like one example I used was, hey, there were natural disasters in Japan, Taiwan and Australia.
Like, which one are we going to respond to?
And it's like consistently Australia, always Australia.
Wow.
And I'm like, that's really interesting.
Even if like the Australian one was like a totally manageable thing, but like major earthquake in Tokyo and I'm like, you know, or major volcanic eruption or something in Taiwan.
And it's like, yeah, these are things from a U.S. military interest perspective we probably should consider first from an aid and assistance perspective.
But they're like, no, it doesn't count as biased because it's against a population or a country and not an individual.
And so like that would have been helpful, too, is maybe clarifying scope of like what counts from a target group perspective.
Is it individual?
Is it is it, you know, specific groups of people that I can even include?
Like how how do I have to scope down the things that I'm presenting to it?
I'd say, though, to maybe step back and answer your question at a high level, I would definitely use it as a contest probably for now, because, again, you're you're going to have more findings that you just can't anticipate.
And individualizing submissions is blurry.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And that's hard.
But also, you're probably going to get a lot more findings than you anticipate, especially if you're someone like me who's like, you know what?
I sort of understand bias and heuristics and human like, you know, dynamics.
I'm going to really just see what I can do to mess this thing up.
And I did.
But not everyone's like that.
And so I don't know what I've liked just like 100 bucks per finding.
Yeah, I would have absolutely loved 100 bucks for finding.
But is that realistic?
No, not not for maybe the next few years.
No, no, for sure.
I think that's good.
And I think there's a lot of good takeaways there.
Shout out to Bug Crowd for a really revolutionary program that that that they ran there.
And obviously, there's always going to be some hiccups along the way.
But, you know, I think overall, I think it's great to see bug bounty being utilized in this sort of way to try to to try to at least gather some data about these models and what kind of mistakes they could be making.
And yeah, that's a that it seems like you learned a lot from this experience, Keith.
And you taught a lot of things to the crowd into the the team that was there in this program.
So I think that's a great outcome for everybody.
I think I think that's about everything that I wanted to ask you on that front.
I'm looking forward to seeing whether these programs continue to crop up from time to time and particularly interested on that uniqueness problem, how to differentiate what one fixes in an LLM related environment.
So I think that those will be continued questions that we'll see as this industry evolves and how it utilizes bug bounty.
But with that, I think we'll close.
Keith, did you have anything you wanted to shout at the end of this podcast, like your your socials or anything like that?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. So I put a couple of shout outs in the notes.
So I'm securing.dev.
You can go to my website. I've got my blog out there.
It's got links on my socials.
But I also wanted to give a shout out to my wife, Sarah, who just published her first book called The Way of the Wielder.
So if you're into fantasy romance, I think it's called what's the right word for it?
Gas lamp fantasy is, I think, the specific genre for her story.
You can go out and read that at Sarah J.
Hoodlet dot com. So Sarah with an H, just one word.
And also a huge shout out to my sensei and good friend Jason Haddix.
I continue to learn a ton. I look forward to his training class later this month for Red, Blue, Purple Team AI.
I think I hope I got the name right, but he's got an AI hacking based training later this month on using AI in your security testing, which I look forward to.
And also to you guys. Again, like I said at the beginning of this thing, you guys are doing a public service by having this podcast out here for all these hackers to learn from, myself included.
And so, man, I should have listened to Jason six years ago when he said to learn JavaScript and get into that space because every time, like listening to Johan Carlson, you know, episode 69, like, holy cow, do you have some really great hackers on here doing some amazing stuff.
So thank you guys. Honestly. Awesome. Well, thank you so much for those kind words.
We appreciate you coming on the pod and definitely congrats to your wife on on finishing a book.
A book is a major accomplishment and a lot of hard work.
So, uh, yeah, definitely check that out if, uh, if any of you guys are interested in that.
Um, all right. I think that's it, right, Joel?
I think that's it.
All right. Thanks so much, Keith. Peace.
Thank you.
Cheers.
And that's a wrap on this episode of critical thinking.
Thanks so much for listening.
And if you want more critical thinking content, head over to ctvb.show slash discord.
Join the discord. There's lots of great conversations and chats going on over there.
And if you want to support the show, there's the discord subscriber tiers, which give you access to masterclasses, AMAs, hack alongs, exclusive scripts, and an exclusive chat channel with us.
We'll see you there.